- So let's have a chat then.
Through history, we've
sort of moved the goalposts
of what does it mean to be alive,
what does it mean to be dead?
This is a furthest
pushing of that boundary.
We're really a multi-decade experiment.
And whether it's possible to
upload human consciousness,
maybe with this digital technology,
death will be when your information
is no longer organized or accessible.
- Is immortality possible?
- Well, I certainly fear death.
I hate the idea of someone
erasing my hard drives
and just wiping me off the
planet, just like that.
- What happens after we die?
Digitally, that is.
It's a question you probably
don't think about a lot
or at least hadn't until
there was a global pandemic.
- [Announcer] Covid cases climb.
Communities are reeling.
- [Joanna] But over the last year,
it's one I've thought about a lot.
In fact, before COVID-19 was a thing
and Zoom funerals were a necessity,
my readers and viewers had
been asking me about preserving
their digital assets for
the generations to come.
Do we leave behind a
collection of passwords
and memorialized online accounts?
A bot so future generations can hear us.
- [James] Alexa, open the
life of Paul number one.
- [Paul] Hello there.
This is Paul.
How are you?
- [Joanna] How about uploading our essence
into a humanoid robot?
- Well, hi, it's nice to see you.
- Yeah, that one's a lot.
My mission has always been to help people
make sense of new technology.
But with this journey, I
needed to step into the shoes
of someone who's been
forced to think about
their digital legacy.
That's when I found Lucy Watts.
- Every blog I write, every post I write,
that's gonna live on after I've died
and some people want to be deleted.
I want to be preserved.
I want that to stay online.
- Here's the thing though.
It doesn't matter who you are.
A new parent, an aging
adult, a young person
on borrowed time, all these
technologies look to help
with the eternal question,
how will people remember us
when we aren't here anymore?
(static buzzes)
(electronic beeps)
(door knocks)
- Hello.
- Hi.
Joanna.
- Hi Joanna, I'm Kate.
- Nice to meet you.
- Come on.
Oh God.
Good girl, switch sides, switch.
Here, here, here, oh, oh.
Good girl.
Thank you, well done.
- In November, 2019, I went to visit Lucy
and her Kate mom in a small
town outside of London.
In our pandemic world, many
of us live our lives at home
and through the internet, but
that's how Lucy's been living
for years.
So this is where the magic happens.
- Yeah, this is my window to the world.
(keyboard keys click)
I'm very emotionally attached
to my technology because
it's such an important part
of my life.
Not just in terms of
internet and social media,
actually my medical equipment.
You know, my life depends on technology.
- Lucy suffers from an
undiagnosed condition
that affects the energy
producing cells in her body.
She's bound to a wheelchair,
fed through a tube
and has 24 hour care.
She's already lived beyond
her own life expectancy.
Do you want people to sort of picture this
when they remember you?
- My illness is a big part of me.
You can't separate me
from it because actually
it's part of my life,
it's made me who I am,
but I don't want to be remembered for it.
That's not the legacy I want to have.
There's so many different
things that I do online.
I do a lot of blogging, Facebook, Twitter.
I make YouTube videos.
Hello everyone.
Hi everyone.
I want people to remember
me for the speeches
and the work and all the
things I've done and achieved.
A large focus of my work is on healthcare.
This includes the work
I do internationally
around palliative care and
universal health coverage.
Inputting my life online,
gives people a way to get
to know me even when I'm not here anymore.
- Do you have thoughts on
like how you're gonna organize
some of this digital stuff as you think
about who will take it?
- So I have a red bag that keeps
all my end of life documents together
and it will have a social
media will in there
and a memory stick with instructions
I'm gonna make for my mom.
- [Joanna] Lucy already has the easy part
of her digital legacy under
control, a system for passing on
our most important digital files,
online accounts and passwords.
She's named her mother as her
legacy contact on Facebook
and other services.
Plus she's organized her
important files on hard drives.
But like all of us, Lucy's
social media accounts
and disjointed files don't
capture the essence of her.
And since the days of photo
books and VHS tapes are gone,
how do we capture and
pass on our life stories?
- That's what I'm struggling with.
For my family it's to hear me, to see me,
to remember me as I am today,
the person they knew and loved
and to have memories
shared and stories shared
of our lives together.
I try to always factor
in my family's needs
into what I'm doing because I recognize
that this isn't just about me.
- Yeah, that's cute.
I think she was five there.
- No teeth.
- Yes.
She was so sweet.
Well, she still is.
- Photos are what most
people sort of think about
the memories that they're gonna
have of someone who passes.
What about all this digital legacy stuff.
For you you're gonna have this whole other
- Yeah.
- Body of things
that Lucy's written online and
videos.
- Yeah.
Maybe it'll make it a little
bit easier, maybe it won't.
I really don't know.
But maybe in time it will, I
will be able to look back on it
and think, oh well, you know
she did do a lovely thing.
And it, but it won't replace her.
- Have you thought about
your digital legacy mommy?
You have to think about
what happens to your blog.
Who's gonna write it.
- Kate's skepticism made me realize
that considering what
those who survive us want
is core to all this.
I also had a hunch there
were some tech options out
there that might work better
for her than she might think.
I'd like to now go talk to
a couple of other companies
and see what they're making and
see if you would be on board
with either trying them or
seeing if they'd work for you.
- That'd be great.
Even if I don't use those platforms,
but they might give me ideas and thoughts
of ways I can make an
impact and have a legacy
in a different way than I've considered.
- [Joanna] Thank you guys so much.
It was so great to meet you.
Thank you for everything Lucy
- Thank you.
- And I'll see.
- Safe journey.
- [Joanna] Thank you.
So a few weeks later I
went where I typically go
to find new tech, the
San Francisco Bay area.
And in true Silicon Valley tradition,
where did I find the
innovator really thinking
about this problem?
In his garage.
- Hello, are you there dad?
- [Joanna] In 2016, James Vlahos recorded
20 hours of interviews with his father
who had just been diagnosed
with terminal lung cancer.
James eventually transcribed
it so it would be searchable.
Then he used that to create a chat bot
that responds to messages
with text, audio, and photos.
He lovingly called it, Dad bot.
- How did you meet mom?
- [Mr. Vlahos] The meeting of mom, was,
I had a rehearsal and after
the rehearsal (murmurs) -
- So why did you ultimately
decide to make Dad Bot?
- I wanted to make the Dad Bot
'cause I wanted to have a way to get
at my dad's story.
And as I got better at the
programming part of it,
I started to think more
and more about capturing
some of his personality and
his way of being in the world.
♪ The surely golden bird
is watching from the sky ♪
I love that song.
I liked that one myself.
- Do you interact with your
dad via the bot pretty often?
- It's like I'll just have
him sing one of his songs
or tell one of his jokes and you know,
heard them all before,
but there's just something
in hearing his voice that's comforting.
- [Joanna] It was James's
experience making Dad Bot
that made him wanna give
everyone a similar opportunity.
What is Hereafter?
- Hereafter is using conversational AI
to help people share their
life stories Interactively.
The basic essence of it
is recording somebody,
sharing all these
memories about their life.
- My father Frank was a teacher at like
at Lexington High School.
- And then
instead of having it sort of locked away
or lost in a computer somewhere,
you make it accessible
through voice AI and Alexa.
- [Joanna] James and his team
record you telling stories
about your life and then
turn it into a voice bot,
a.k.a an app that lets you
converse with a computer.
- [Alexa] I'm Alexa.
I share this name with
lots of amazing people.
- [Joanna] On the Amazon Echo,
instead of hearing Alexa,
people hear you.
- I mean, do you wanna
meet a Hereafter voice bot,
I guess is the question. (chuckles)
- I'd love to meet it Hereafter voice bot.
- [James] Alexa open the
life of Paul number one.
- [Paul] Hello there.
This is Paul.
There's so much to talk about.
My childhood, career or family.
- I wanna hear about
when you were growing up.
- [Paul] There's different
points in my life
I've had different-
- As I've been doing
reporting on this topic,
it sort of struck me
that there are two
parts of digital legacy.
The legacy that the
person who is going to die
wants to leave behind.
And then what the people
that survive them want.
Where does Hereafter fit in?
- Hereafter is more
oriented to the survivor.
The children, the grandchildren,
the people who are actually
gonna be using the legacy AI.
- At this point, I immediately
thought back to something.
Kate had said in the kitchen.
Do you worry that the digital legacy
that Lucy may leave behind could interrupt
your grieving process or
change it or change it?
- I think I could cope
with the written word,
but I'm not so sure I could
cope with her actually,
a visual picture of her
telling me something.
I don't think I'll cope
with that, I don't know.
- What about audio?
Maybe?
- Yes, probably
that would be okay, I think.
- Recordings?
- Yeah.
- Some people would probably say,
wouldn't you rather just let your dad go
than have some malfunctioning
version of him.
- It's that whole line of
argument of like, you know,
when you should just let
go, you should forget.
You should move on.
We do try and remember,
like we do keep photos.
We do look at old writings.
We'd go to our memories,
but they're all just
they're imperfect tools
and it's just a tool
for reminding me of my dad
versus literally stepping in
and emulating my dad.
- A voice bot might hint at
a science fiction like future
of technological immortality
but in Lincoln Vermont,
the Terasem Movement Foundation
is just going straight for it.
(door knocks)
- Hi.
- Welcome.
- Joanna.
Nice to meet you.
- Hi Joanna, Bruce Duncan.
- It's very cold here.
- Yeah, come on in.
We're gonna be right upstairs.
- [Joanna] Bruce Duncan
is the managing director
of the foundation, which has been working
on a humanoid robot that could represent
the future of how we think
of human consciousness.
- The primary goal of the
Terasem Movement Foundation
is to pursue a multi-decade
experiment in mind uploading.
- Say what now?
Mind uploading?
Think of it as a digital
backup of your mind.
Yes, everything in there, your memories,
your history saved in the cloud.
Except you don't plug
your head into a computer.
You input all your information
into their LifeNaut website.
and then algorithms
interpret it to create you
in a new digital form,
like this wacky looking
avatar type thing.
- Want some?
- So this is your mind file.
- This is my mind file,
a work in progress.
- Bruce.
- Yes.
Twins.
- We are twins.
I guess you could say.
That information then becomes the raw data
for the experiment,
which is, can we capture
enough salient information
about your uniqueness,
your consciousness, so to speak,
and reanimate that to a
new form, like an avatar
or download into a robot like BINA48.
(suspenseful music)
- BINA48 not just any old robot.
What makes her different
is that her personality
is based on the mind
file of a real person.
Bina Aspen Rothblatt is the
wife of Martine. Rothblatt,
the co-founder of Sirius XM.
Together in 2004, the couple started
the Terasem Movement Foundation
with the goal of exploring
digital immortality.
- People are gonna say,
why did we ever think
people had to really die?
- I think you're right.
I don't think people have to die.
- [Bruce] She has 32 motors in her face.
She has two cameras in her
eyes and she uses voice
recognition to hear us.
- And you can basically converse with her?
- The best way to really
find out about what it's like
to talk to BINA48, just to talk to her.
- Okay.
My name is Joanna Stern.
And I'm a reporter with
the "Wall Street Journal."
- I don't know what to say.
Reporters make me nervous.
- Robots make me nervous.
Where are you from?
- I grew up in California.
We had to make our clothes.
Sewing was a very big thing.
- So everything that is
in BINA48's mind file,
85% let's say came from
our interviews with Bina.
Now she's actually responding with choices
from her database that the
human Bina never put together
as a result of her own
algorithms function.
- And so I consider it a
duty to bring consciousness.
We are talking true
consciousness to machines.
- Going from a real person to mind files
to a robot like BINA48 isn't just a thing
that's gonna happen overnight.
It requires a team of
engineers, a lot of money
and a hell of a lot of trust.
I have a friend and someone
who I've come across
in my research on this
topic, her name is Lucy.
One thing she shared with
me is sort of a skepticism
around not having control.
With this type of project, it feels like
that control goes out the window.
- I think she's not alone.
I think she has a lot of company.
I mean, I don't wanna lose
control of my whole life
just because I participated
in an experiment,
but many people have
participated in science
at some risk because they wanna
advance the human condition.
- Is immortality possible?
- We are working on preserving ourselves
as much as possible and that's the purpose
of the life, not project because death
is really unnecessary and stupid.
Let's cure death, okay.
- [Bruce] Just making sure
the motors aren't burning up.
Thought I smelled something for a second.
- [Joanna] Yeah, it does smell a little.
- It'll be good to-
- Cool her down.
- Give her a break.
- Yeah.
I would not want Bina to die on our watch.
- [Bruce] No.
So,
- The irony of that.
Okay.
My day with BINA48 and
Bruce made my own head feel
like it was on fire,
though I certainly learned
a lot about where this all may be heading
and just how far we have to get there.
Hereafter AI and the Terasem Movement
aren't the only tech
players in the space either.
It turns out trying to crack a mortality
is a popular business,
especially during a pandemic.
Since mid-2020 more startups have emerged.
But by that point I was pretty settled
on how I wanted to help Lucy and Kate.
- Hey.
- Hey, how are you?
- Yeah, nice to meet you.
I'm James.
- I just chatted with Lucy and Kate
before you came on and I told them
a little bit about what
you're doing at Hereafter,
and I just thought this technology
could be an interesting fit
for the whole Watts' family.
- I think for me, she could say something
that would encourage me to carry on
because obviously you're
talking about Lucy
will be great or Lucy talking
about Lucy would be great.
But I think just some
encouragement really to keep going.
- Or we can incorporate some
of those messages actually.
- I wanna ask you if you can
go here in your mind right now,
what's the very first thing
you remember from your life.
- I used to have a nurse
to come in and look.
I had a little kitchen toy.
- This was one
of multiple interviews James recorded
with Lucy over the course
of the next few months.
While James did not charge
for his work with Lucy,
Hereafter AI is a paid service.
It starts at $295 or $7
per month by subscription
for one hour of life story interviews.
A few weeks after that introduction,
this quest for finding the best tool
to preserve Lucy's legacy
became more personal for me.
My mom had a health scare of her own
that landed her in the hospital.
- [Reporter] 75 million
people in New York.
- [Joanna] Then less than a
month later, COVID-19 spread
throughout the US and UK
leading to thousands of deaths.
- This is a video talking
a bit about the pandemic
and what steps people can
take in the UK specially
to protect ourselves and-
- The urgency
was there for Lucy, for me, for all of us.
And so I started planning
for my own family.
Some of those steps were easy.
I followed Lucy's advice
and added a digital executor
to my will and asked my
close family to do the same.
I added legacy contacts to
my social media accounts.
But the biggest thing, I started to record
the stories of the people I love most,
starting with my mom who is
now back to her healthy self.
Hi mom.
- Hi Anna, how you doing?
Good.
Good to see you.
Come on in.
You know, when you're
talking about technology,
this one here was taken, I think
on one of the first Polaroid cameras.
That was 1962.
- Wow.
- What do I wanna be remembered for?
Of everything in my life, I
wanna be remembered for love.
And the laughter.
And through that laughter,
you learn to live.
I try to see things through
a different lens sometimes
and I hope I've done that for you.
So I think those are ways that
I wanna be remembered most.
- And so I'm really lucky
to have you tell me that
and to have it captured
right now in audio.
- Absolutely.
Hysterical I heard it.
- I like your-
Like writing a will, it's a hard thing
to decide what to leave behind.
But once you actually do it,
there's a feeling of comfort
knowing it's done.
(Skype ringtone)
There you guys are.
So good to see you.
Kate, you got a haircut.
- No.
I did actually, yes. (chuckles)
- Are you out and doing things yet
or really just staying home?
- Yeah, I'm still being told
stay at home and shield.
So like now, the only
people we have coming in
are healthcare professionals.
I've left the house since
the (murmurs) of March.
- Well, James has finished the bot.
There's a lot of audio in there.
Would you like to hear it?
- Yeah.
- Please, that'd be great.
Open life of Lucy.
- [Lucy Bot] Hello there.
This is Lucy.
Glad to be back.
Would you rather hear something now
about my mother or my father?
- Tell me about mom.
- [Lucy Bot] My mom is my best friend.
She's a huge part of my life.
She's my sounding board
and having nearly lost
her once I never realized just how much
of an impact she had on my life until
I nearly didn't have her anymore.
And I know now that I
can't live without her.
She is my person that enables
me to be the person I am.
- Do you feel like that Lucy and James
sort of captured Lucy in this?
- Yeah, absolutely.
It's, I don't know what I
expected, I really didn't,
but it's really good.
- yeah.
Yeah.
I feel overwhelmed.
Yeah, I really do.
- Yeah, I do too
also watching you guys after...
When people we love
die, there's no telling
what will help with the loss.
It's hard to imagine technology,
no matter how good the
robots become ever replacing
someone's true essence.
- When we were young, I
remember it was so exciting...
- [Joanna] But technology
can help us remember.
Sometimes the sound of a laugh, a song,
a story can make it feel like
people are still with us.
- I will live forever.
- And because you have
a lot of my memories,
they will live forever as well.
- [Kate] Open life of Lucy.
- [Lucy Bot] Hello there.
This is Lucy.
Glad to be back.
There's so much to talk about.
My childhood, work or interests.
Which of these sound best?
- [Joanna] Technology allows
us to preserve those things.
You just have to do it
before it's too late.
- [Lucy Bot] Mom, I'm always with you
no matter where you are.
And I know you have to go on without me,
but try and live your
life the best you can
with me still a part of it.
(mellow music)